And I want to read you something that
nature wrote.
It's perhaps the most famous thing he
ever said,
although it's almost entirely taken out
of context and misquoted,
and if not,
ms dot quartered,
at least misunderstood because nature
was one of these strange people who was
capable of living 50 or even 100 years
into the future,
and although he was,
is generally regarded as an enemy of
Christianity and superstition and was
certainly an unbelievably outspoken
opponent of Christian traditionalism,
he also knew that if you let the old
gods die,
the probability that blood would flood
the land was virtually 100 percent.
So let me read you what he wrote.
Have you not heard of that?
Mad Man who lit a lantern in the bright
morning hours,
ran to the market place and cried
incessantly.
I seek God as many of those who do not
believe in God were standing around just
then he provoked.
Must much laughter.
Why did he get lost?
Said one.
Did he lose his way like a child said
another or is he hiding?
Is he afraid of us?
Has he gone on a voyage or immigrated?
That's the yelled and laughed.
The Madman jumped into their midst and
pierced them with his glances.
Where there is God,
he cried.
I shall tell you,
we have killed him.
You and I,
all of us are as murderers,
but how have we done this?
How were we able to drink up the sea?
Who gave us the sponge to wipe away the
entire horizon?
What did we do when we unchained this
earth from its sun weather?
Is it moving now with or are we moving
now way from all sons?
Are we not plunging continuously
backwards,
sideward,
forward in all directions?
Is there any opera down left?
Are we not straying as though through an
infinite nothing?
Do we not feel the breath of empty
space?
Has it not become colder,
is not night and more night coming on
all the while.
Must not lanterns be lit in the morning.
Do we not hear anything yet of the noise
of the grave diggers who are burying
God?
Do we not smell anything yet of God's
decomposition?
God's to decompose.
God is dead.
God remains dead.
We have killed him.
How shall we,
the murderer of all murderers,
comfort ourselves?
What was holiest and most powerful of
all that the world has yet owned,
has bled to death under our knives?
Who will wipe this blood office?
What water is there for us to clean
ourselves?
What festivals of Atonement,
what sacred game show we have to invent
is not the greatness of this deed too
great for us?
Must we not ourselves become God simply
to seem worthy of it?
Well,
as you can tell,
that's a much different notion from the
casual God is dead quotation that's most
generally associated with nature.
Well,
what is he saying?
What he's saying?
Something like this system like
Christianity or any system that's Qa,
that's oriented the society for
thousands and thousands of years,
can't simply be eradicated by a casual
gesture,
without consequences in suing and its
aftermath.
What consequences will need you to says,
well,
we'll no longer know up from down.
What does he mean by that?
Metaphorically?
Well Up.
That's where you're headed,
right and down.
That's what you want to stay away from,
and when you eradicate the most
fundamental presuppositions of your
system,
of values,
then there is no up and there is no down
and then where are you?
Precisely.
Well,
it's not so easy.
It's not so easy to say having not
necessarily ever been in that position.
What is your life like when you don't
know up from down?
Is it merely neutral is merely no value
left or could it possibly be the case
that if up and down and both being
eradicated,
that the place that you're left in is
something much more akin to a permanent
state of suffering because maybe it's
only the case that the constant capacity
to thrive for up in being enough that
you believe in.
The constant striving for up is actually
what makes your life bearable to you,
and if you lost the sense of up and
down,
the place that you would end up would be
not so much neutral as terrible.
Now,
if you have any belief system at all,
you do this,
so let's say you're an advocate of
leftwing politics.
You take a pro environmental stance or
an anti corporate stance,
which is a relatively common thing to do
among undergraduates.
What do you do when you hold that belief
system?
You view the world as it lays itself out
and you explained the manner in which it
manifests itself in terms of the axioms
of that belief system and you may know
that you can do it right.
You can tell a credible story about why
the world is the way it is by adopting,
say an anti corporate perspective
because there are all sorts of terrible
things about the world that are a
consequence say of corporate
maneuvering,
and you might also say that and Piaget
would say this,
that it's a necessary developmental
stage to acquire allegiance to a given
belief system.
Why?
Well,
any APP is better than none.
That might be the first observation,
so even if your belief system is
relatively insufficient and easily
challenged on intellectual grounds and
perhaps not very complete anyways,
the fact that it does lay out a moral
structure for you and tell you,
good for me,
evil and right from wrong.
That's a.
that's a plus.
That's an advantage.
Now it's relative intellectual weakness
and it's incoherence.
Assuming it is incoherent to some
degree,
that's a flaw,
but that mean that the effort to
establish a system like that is
worthless.
It's worthwhile and need just said,
say with regards to Christianity and
Europe,
he said,
well,
the errors,
intellectual and moral of Institutional
Christianity are essentially beyond
count,
but there's one thing you have to
remember.
First of all,
in ordering of that sort is necessary
because the alternative,
which is always hidden from you in so
far as you're inside a moral system,
the alternative as far worse chaos
that's worse.